i feel like after all this work you're
still gonna like the mcdonald's one
better that's my prediction
[Music]
so we both really love fast food one of
the things i love about fast food though
is how easy it is to get it go drive
through and pick it up sometimes you
just need something quick and tasty and
we were talking the other day and we
were thinking like i wonder if we could
make some of this stuff it seems pretty
simple fast food is like a couple
ingredients but is the magic
in the processedness of it that's what i
really want to know one of my favorite
things of course is the egg mcmuffin
from mcdonald's
so today we're going to see if we can
recreate it from scratch and see how
well we can do technically you don't
really need to make this because you
could go get it so i was looking into
this and i think what we need to do is
we need to make some homemade eggs oh my
god we're baking
and then obviously egg american cheese
and canadian bacon there's a lot of
steps when you make it yourself we're
gonna be making some real homemade
english muffins that might be the
hardest part oh it's definitely gonna be
the hardest part those are gonna be
tough
we are gonna actually compare our
mcdonald's egg mcmuffin to our homemade
mcmuffin and we're going to see how ours
measures up that's like a baking time oh
my god
i would say i'm like a medium skill
level bakers but i do love baking a lot
i've never made english muffins i would
say i'm very novice but now that i'm
older i need to feed myself this really
instills me with a lot of confidence
this recipe i actually got from the king
arthur flower like the flower company
this one seems like the simplest
literally all we have to do is put
everything here into this and then we
put it on a standing mixer and let it go
for a bit that's four and a half cups of
flour okay these are just for the
biscuits we're starting out with
biscuits
muffins why do i keep calling them
biscuits i don't know everything's a
biscuit to me okay this is sugar okay
salt yeast okay yay
yeast softened butter
all right so the egg we have to beat a
little bit okay so
baking is all about the science baking
is a lot of chemistry you have to really
hope you got it right that's why you're
good at it i think because i'm good at
chemistry yeah yeah i was going to
chemistry in high school i don't think i
ever really figured out how to balance
an equation we have one and three
quarters cups of lukewarm milk all right
ready the trick with this is supposedly
that you're not supposed to over mix it
so we have to be a little careful oh i
wouldn't know when something is fully
mixed i guess when it just looks like
the ingredients are together right so
the recipe says that we're supposed to
beat it until it is texture of satin but
stretchy medium-high for five minutes
okay
wow
[Music]
i don't know if that's satin but it's
smooth and it's definitely stretchy it's
now see that dough so now basically we
have to let this rise for like an hour
or two and then we're just gonna
cover it with a towel and then we pray
so we hope it rises it won't get like
probably double the size but going puffy
this is a lot of time for
egg mcmuffin
[Music]
i'm excited
it rose it definitely rose now we
deflate it gently the way that i've
always done that is just kind of punch
it do we do it in this board yeah yeah
so you want to do it like three times
[Music]
oh it feels so good
oh my god look at that wow
okay
beautiful it's supposed to make 16. i
don't know if that's gonna happen okay
i'm just gonna divide it in half and
then okay and we make little balls yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
so we can put them in this you can kind
of put it in then kind of like squish it
down again so it's interesting i didn't
realize before making these that you
actually fry english muffins you don't
actually put them in the oven
that's why it's like brown on both sides
baking is fun do you bake ever no
never i buy store-bought dough
and then we're supposed to cover them
and let them rise for a little bit okay
[Music]
they're little
pillows yeah they are like little
pillows actually they're great so you
actually kind of fry them you need to do
like nonstick cooking spray we're using
coconut oil but i think you can use
whatever you want whatever and then you
put on a bunch of semolina it's like a
special kind because you know like the
bottom of the english muffins you buy
how they have all the yellow stuff
oh my gosh
[Music]
and then you put some on the top
you can take them out of little molds
they cook like that for 7 to 15 minutes
on each side this is a long time
we've been going for about an hour you
guys but we're close i'm factoring that
into my final decision i mean that's
fair
all right you ready to flip yeah i'm
ready these look so good and puffy
oh wow
beautifully brown wow that's almost
perfect so we wait another
seven minutes now we wait again okay
great let's check back in with these
guys soon
they're looking beautiful i think yeah
they're done let's take them off
i think the hardest part's over okay so
now it's just eggs bacon and cheese
great i found this recipe on abc and
mcdonald's had released their recipe for
the
muffin wow
gotta grease the pan i'm just waiting
for this to get hot
it's not how you should check safety was
not of a priority to you premium
canadian bacon that does look like the
mcdonald's meat so you do it like a
minute-ish on each side supposedly
nothing better than a sizzle i love a
sizzle
all right i'm gonna just go for it
before
you can actually use this too the egg
what did you see that somewhere it saw
that one of the chefs of mcdonald's does
this wow that is a hat all right then
you put a little bit of water in
around the edge okay and then you let it
go for like two three minutes all right
i'm gonna let those cool
apparently what you're supposed to do is
you're not supposed to cut english
muffins you're supposed to like fork it
around the side and then pull it apart
so it's all like craggly you can kind of
just like work it around the sides yeah
oh my gosh
that's beautiful
oh my god these are going to be so good
i can't wait that's probably done
yep
so the cheese we have what is this
american this is just yeah good old
american all right moment of truth
carefully get an egg cheese cheese goes
first so cheese
oh my god oh it's so beautiful oh
are we chefs and then canadian bacon oh
my gosh
wow
oh my gosh this looks so good
[Music]
[Applause]
so these are
the mcdonald's ones these are the
homemade egg mcmuffins
i'm very proud of myself they look great
they look really good they look very
similar to the real one they look like
the commercial version because they're a
little thicker these are a little more
toasty you can see maybe we should have
toasted ours also i realized that i
forgot to put butter on ours you could
also use margarine which is what i have
currently yeah
oh my god
it's time to taste how well we did so
how are we going to grade ours i feel
like we have to put in like the time and
effort as a category general like taste
maybe we could talk about costs and
these obviously cost more part of the
cost too is like our time several hours
we have to wait for the dough to rise
i say we dive in should we eat the real
things let's try the real thing i need
to
set the bar i really hope that these
taste the same i hope they like really
hold their own
mcdonald's version
it's great classic i love mcdonald's i
do too i love it so much it's so bad
it's such a like bad addiction you have
that melted cheese in there you have
that egg the ham and the muffins taste
great too it's nice and like bouncy
muffin
i do taste a little bit of the crunch
and the toast of the muffin we didn't
toast ours nearly enough looking at this
i feel like they cooked their canadian
bacon a lot less than we cooked ours
yeah our canadian bacon's super toasty
the egg looks really similar their
cheese is yellower all right now let's
go for our homemade one i'm so excited i
hope it tastes just as good i feel like
this is gonna drip oh yeah
oh no
um oh man holy sh
it's so good this is so much better oh
good you guys holy [ __ ]
so good this is really good like the
homemade muffin you can taste that it's
homemade it tastes very simple it tastes
very very similar i would say the only
difference is really the muffin because
the muffin tastes really fresh the
muffin has a very different texture i'm
gonna go back and i feel like the muffin
of the homemade one is less springy i
don't know if that's good or bad but it
just tastes different but everything
else tastes remarkably similar i think
we nailed it like this is definitely on
par with the mcdonald's one i'm gonna
have to cast my vote the homemade
version took hours about four hours to
make so the time category definitely
gets knocked some points totally this we
got it in
like 10 minutes 10 minutes cost wise the
homemade one is more expensive but you
can make way more of them so if we'd
made like breakfast for 16 people maybe
that's more cost effective i think we
could our own time included then the
homemade are way more expensive for me i
am such a homemade person i will always
go for homemade stuff even though
mcdonald's ones are very good i think
taste wise the homemade one wins for me
for me i would say that the taste is so
similar i would give this one a little
extra point for taste i'm not gonna lie
the homemade muffin you can taste the
difference there you know it's a little
spongier it's so minuscule the
difference there's something nostalgic
about the mcdonald's eggs muffin and the
time it took to make these is really a
deal breaker for me so i'm gonna vote
mcdonald's all the way you know what on
a fun saturday or sunday with a lot of
time maybe i would do this what i like
mcdonald's for is the ease and the
convenience and we made a really good
one and that's what i'm proud of i feel
like for me the homemade one wins but
they are so close they're so close look
at what we created we made this and you
know what it tastes so good as well it's
amazing
wow high five
what recipe do you want to spend four
hours on next oh god you know what
comment below if you've ever done
something like this before if you have
any homemade swaps of your favorite fast
food if i was presented with the choice
of do you want to spend four hours
making the homemade one or do i want to
go to mcdonald's for five minutes i
would definitely choose the mcdonald's
one this is a lot of effort for this and
thank you mcdonald's for doing that for
me